au château de blois la visite en famille
continue séverine la guide va proposer
aux enfants d'aurélie une plongée au
coeur du 16ème siècle grâce à un outil
très efficace
une tablette interactive et cette
tablette ça nous permet de voir comment
étaient les cuisines royales et ce qu'on
pouvait faire à manger
et puis regardez je vais faire tourner
une scène suivre j'entendais sont tombés
le feu le feu crépite en fait sur la
développer un outil et dans certaines
salles on a des reconstitutions donc en
3d de ce qu'était le château comment il
était donc décoré ou comment fonctionner
ses cuisines blois et le deuxième
château de la région avoir mis en place
cette application et les enfants sont
conquis
on écoutait l'instrument musique on va
écouter le son qui s'est entendu
donc c'est vrai qu'avec ce nouvel outil
les enfants sont captés et ça leur
permet de concrétiser
en fait les thèmes que nous on aborde en
visite il ya vraiment eu un avant après
parce que nous aussi il a fallu qu'on
apprenne à les utiliser de façon bien
apportés par rapport au contenu des
visites mais ça illustre en fait le
propos est maintenant on va aller
c'est le fameux escalier de françois 1er
avec majesté ont fait ça bien gardé
l'argent c'est beau on voit toute la
cour du château
on voit même le château de louis xii et
on va arriver dans le logis du roy les
enfants je joue c'est bien la révérence
on va se baisser
devant le roi françois il est là un jour
françois 1er sa majesté c'est super on
s'imagine que c'est compliqué de visiter
les châteaux avec les enfants j'ai
beaucoup de lecteurs qui mise mais quand
je suis avec quatre enjeux c'est super
simple on peut s'arranger il ya des
jours de visite adaptée il ya des
applications selon les périodes et des
thèmes aidant les enfants ils sont vite
accro aux histoires
donc non c'est très simple mais
décidément maintenir l'attention de la
petite bande demande beaucoup
d'inventivité
vous allez essayer d'en retrouver simple
le portrait du roi dont vous avez la
représentation lucie nice vient super
musique objets et fraises presque
d'époque les enfants droit les garçons
était habillé en robe à peu près jusqu'à
l'âge de 7 ans donc là c'est un petit
garçon qui s'appelle louis et qui va
devenir roi
ils portent la même chose que toi autour
du cou fin de la visite pour aurélie et
ses enfants eh bien je crois qu'on a
atteint le maximum en termes de
concentration deux heures indique oui
ils ont été très attentifs
maintenant c'était vraiment chouette
merci beaucoup c'est win je crois qu'ils
ont adoré
mais d'autres surprises les attendent
non loin de là